Alternant d'abord un commentaire drôle
tous les jours avec le secrétaire
national du pcf le jeu celui de claire
sur cette affaire ou plutôt cette
partielle de 2009 soit parce que les
délais les plus brefs de temps en tout
cas les résultats du premier tour
son cas est assez effrayant pour la
gauche
un an je crois que le ps doit tirer les
leçons
tout ce qui était en train de se passer
c'est là
la quatrième fois ça vient d'être dit
que la gauche est éliminée dès le
deuxième tour dans une élection
et puis c'est pas seulement évidemment
la ferc à lusaka jouer terriblement
villeneuve-sur-lot the mais c'est la
ferc l usage plus
le roger de l'austérité des politiques
qui sont menées
donc il faut changer de cap d'urgence
pour cette nuit hier à montreuil
l'euro va réunir
à l'initiative du parti communiste du
front de gauche dj des gens venus de
toutes les familles de la gauche
le secrétaire nationale des verts
pour marie-noëlle lienemann de riz
manuellement et du parti socialiste
parce qu'il faut être
il faut punir toutes les formes légales
afin de relancer le parti socialiste
mais vous savez ça avec les verser de
l'eau je vois pas ce que c'est qu'un
accès par son envie de réparer dans la
situation de l'an dernier que la
situation d'aujourd'hui c'est tout on
voit que les électeurs du front de
gauche qui est nouveau
ils sont là dans les rendez-vous ou
dans les dom les dents les partiels au
soutien
on progresse très légèrement
e mais les électeurs socialistes sont
aujourd'hui complètement déboussolée
parce que la politique qui les attendait
et bien ce qui est mon étalon verse
eh bien il faut punir ces forces-là il
faut que nous travaillons à rassembler
ses électeurs aujourd'hui déboussolés
ou les au mieux les unira que si on le
fait sur un projet de rupture avec le cp
lys règlement le cadre de l'accord
national marine le pen vous avez volé
rsa c'est là on est dans un tournant
historique qui se développe
nous avons été tout simplement
l'électorat ouvrier au jour le jour 3
que l'électorat qu'il y en ait qui
n'est pas au rendez-vous hier les voix
qui manquent
pourtant si on les a vus
oui oui c'est ça les voix qui manque au
parti socialiste elle se sauve elle ne
se suivent des gens qui ne se sont pas
déplacés
qui n'a pas eu à vivre à l'étranger
cc c'est des gens qui ne savent plus
aujourd'hui où ils en sont
parce qu ils ont
voulue une rupture avec les politiques
de sarkozy et ils ont
pour le moment par cette rupture
ils ne savent plus comment
pour s'y retrouver et bien c'est à nous
de leur donner des repères
au front de gauche
outre paris le front de gauche n'y
arrivera pas donc c'est pour ça que moi
je travaille à rassembler des
écologistes et socialistes qui avec
nouveaux clients il ya une autre
politique possible qui ont vécu un
hiver de razac elle est signée
françois hollande hier soir sur m6 non
jerry leiber arrestation je suis victime
de la question encore sur le village sur
l'autre
dimanche prochain nous a appelé à
faire barrage au front national il pas
une voix pour le front national le
retrait de nouveaux députés du front
national
sorel une cote très mauvais signal
parce que ce qui doit être construit
ses études une alternative
à gauche quant aux politiques
d'austérité et donc
% il ne faut pas compter sur nous pour
banaliser en quoi que ce soit à
l'entrée possible au député du front
national
même à l'assemblée nationale